V Voici nos analystes :
MaMartine Biron, Michel David
etet Christian Dufour.
ReRebonjour. Deux heures plus
tatard, c'est intéressant ce qui
ététait avec nous, ils ont analé
àà chaud le discours tout de
susuite après. Christian, vous
avavez été séduits par l'exercie
auau complet. Je vais commencer
avavec vous, vous retenez quoi?
QuQu'est-ce que vous reste en te
susur ce que Legault veut faire
dadans les prochains mois?
- - Ce qui me frappe, c'est
ququ'indépendamment des différes
éléléments dont Monsieur Legaula
paparlé, qu'on trouve ça réalise
ouou pas, il y a un élémentt
nonouveau pour moi très clair et
trtrès important, c'est que j'ai
réréalisé que François Legault
avavait une vision d'avenir avec
unun souffle. C'est nouveau pare
quque je ne croyais pas ça,
cocontrairement aux autres
paparties. Les autres parties, s
onont un ancrage idéologique. La
CACAQ est une coalition un peu
héhétéroclite avec François
LeLegault qui est bien
sysympathique, et j'avais
l'l'impression que c'était
efefficace électoralement, mais
auaujourd'hui j'ai réalisé qu'iy
avavait une vision pour l'avenir
dudu Québec.
- - Qui repose sur une cohésion.
- - C'est un mélange d'éléments
trtrès pragmatiques. C'est très
imimportant ce qu'il a dit sur a
sasanté. Je trouvais ça
inintéressant. À la fin, il y
avavait un nationalisme québéco.
LaLa façon dont s'est agencée,
c'c'est l'élément nouveau.
FrFrançois Legault a une vision
d'd'avenir pour le Québec et c't
unune découverte.
- - Michel David?
- - Ce qui frappe beaucoup, c'et
ququ'on ne voit absolument pas e
trtrace d'une quelconque remisen
ququestion du modèle québécois.l
y y a des choses qui ne marchent
papas, mais par exemple dans la
sasanté, il n'est pas question u
totout de faire plus de place au
prprivé dans la tête de Monsieur
LeLegault. Les agences, on n'en
veveut plus. Tout le monde avait
imimaginé la CAQ avant son
élélection comme une espèce de
gogouvernement libéral 2.0.
CeCe n'est pas ceux à quoi on a
asassisté dans les premières
anannées de Monsieur Legault. Et
cece n'est pas ce qu'il nous
anannonce non plus.
LeLe danger du démantèlement de
l'l'État, on ne le voit pas du
totout. Ça m'a frappé aussi que
dadans son discours, il a parlé
lolongtemps de santé éducation.
OnOn a vu la réaction des miliex
d'd'affaires à son refus, il se
réréjouit pratiquement de la
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre en
didisant bravo pour les employés
ququi vont avoir un n meilleur
sasalaire.
- - C'est intéressant que vous
sosoulignez ça, il prend la
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre sousn
auautre angle. Il dit que dans e
fofond, c'est une bonne nouvelle
popour les 4 millions et quelque
10100 000 Québécois, ils vont
avavoir de meilleurs salaires.
OuOui il y a des entreprises qui
mamanquent de main-d'oeuvre, mas
elelles vont se réinventer et êe
plplus produit.
- - Il voit un nouveau pack socl
enentre l'employeur et les
ememployés. Pour revenir sur la
ququestion de santé, je pense qe
c'c'est un des points les plus
imimportants de son discours et
c'c'était moins présent dans son
didiscours en 2018.
OnOn voit qu'il tire des leçonse
cece qui est arrivé avec la
papandémie et des erreurs qui ot
eueu lieu. La main droite ne
sasavait pas trop ce que la main
gagauche faisait. Il veut répar.
CeCe que je retiens beaucoup de
cecet aspect, il a dit qu'il
vovoulait décentraliser les
seserviceses en santé et il a
prprononcé chaque syllabe bien
clclairement pour qu'on le
cocomprenne.
- - Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire?
- - Qu'il risque de démanteler e
papartie de la réforme barrette
ququi était décentralisée les
seservices de santé. Les centres
rérégionaux de santé et de
seservices sociaux qui étaient s
mamal dans les petites villes qi
onont fermé une après l'autre.
LeLe citoyen qui pouvait avoir n
seservice dans le bas Saint-
LaLaurent à 10 ou 15 minutes de
chchez lui doit maintenant faire
20200 km pour obtenir le même
seservice. Est-ce qu'il va
rerefaire, défaire la réforme
babarrette? On s'en va sur des
dédébats assez importants et des
chchangements majeurs.
- - Un petit quelque chose à ce
quque dit Martine, Monsieur
LeLegault a dit que le seul rôle
dudu ministre de la santé devrat
êêtre de fixer des objectifs est
dede s'assurer du suivi de
rérésultats. On est très loin de
lala quasi micro gestion que le
miministre de la santé exerce sr
lele réseau depuis des années, t
ququi a connu son paroxysme de
avavec Monsieur barrette.
SoSouvenez-vous de Monsieur Bolc
ququi avait toujours les deux
mamains dans la pâte.
- - C'est clair que le diable et
dadans les détails. Je suis assz
alallergique à ceux qui ont des
vivisions, je m'étonne moi-même.
OnOn peut voir que c'est une
opopération de manipulation très
hahabile. Je dis simplement qu'l
a a une vision. Jusqu'à quel pot
elelle est solide? Dans le domae
lilinguistique, n'a pas laissé
enentendre qu'il pouvait changer
d'd'idée. Je pense que
l'l'application de la loi 101 au
cécégep, par exemple. C'est
imimportant de dire que le premr
miministre a une vision assez
ststimulante. D'habitude, ça
m'm'ennuie à mourir ce genre de
didiscours. On ne sait pas qui a
rérédigé son discours, mais la
fafaçon dont s'était présenté, l
y y avait un côté stimulant. C't
unune réalité politique.
- - Il y avait dans ce discours
dedes promesses de 2018 qu'on
rérépète et qu'on répète un peu
plplus fermement, comme par
exexemple avoir accès à un méden
dede famille. On est loin du
cocompte. Et voici ce qu'il ditu
mémédecin de famille.
- - On a eu beaucoup
dede discussions avec les
rereprésentants des médecins
dede famille depuis trois ans.
MaMais je dois dire que
jeje commence à m'impatienter,
pupuis les Québécois aussi.
J'J'ai toujours pensé qu'il valt
mimieux s'entendre avec
leles médecins, mais s'il le fa,
onon va pas hésiter à imposer
unune conclusion parce que
leles Québécois s'attendent
àà être pris en charge, puis
àà avoir des services de premièe
liligne dans un délai raisonnab.
- - Il l'avait déjà dit dans une
enentrevue où je ne me souviens
plplus où qu'il allait sévir, ou
pepeut-être une loi pour oblige.
IlIl le répète parce qu'il y a u
rarattrapage à faire.
- - L'objectif qu'il avait fixén
202018, on était très loin pour
l'l'accès au médecin de famille.
JeJe pense qu'il ne sent pas de
bobonne volonté de la part des
mémédecins. Monsieur Barette avt
auaussi essayé d'utiliser le bân
avavec la loi 20. Mais à ce
momoment, c'est le premier
miministre de l'époque qui lui
avavait tiré le tapis sous les
pipieds. Maintenant, c'est le
prpremier ministre qui dit qu'il
enen a assez. Je pense qu'il n'a
pepersonne qui va tirer le tapis
sosous les pieds de Monsieur
LeLegault. Cette fois, je pense
quque les médecins devraient
coconsidérer cette menace comme
ététant bien réelle.
- - Toute l'architecte sur qu'is
onont en tête d'un nouveau syste
dede santé plus efficace, ça ne
fofonctionne pas. Les médecins
dodoive entrer dans la danse.
- - C'est le bout de la réforme
BaBarette que Monsieur Legault a
prprobablement garder. Il va
ssûrement mettre sa menace à
exexécution. On a senti qu'il
ététait impatient. Ce que Monsir
BaBarette disait aller, c'est qe
leles médecins de famille contet
tetenu de la rémunération ne
trtravaillent pas autant d'heur.
PlPlusieurs mécanismes avaient é
mimis en place comme Bonjour saé
ququi permettait aux médecins de
memettre leur horaire sur
InInternet, etet ça permettait u
gogouvernement de moniteur et qi
trtravail ou non, mais les
mémédecins ne veulent pas
l'l'utiliser parce qu'ils ne
veveulent pas être surveillés.
C'C'est une promesse électoralee
d'd'autres chefs de parti et ça
n'n'aboutit pas. On a des médecs
susuffisamment pour la populatin
auau Québec, alors il va vouloir
sosortir le bâton.
- - Je trouve que c'est très
rérévélateur qu'il a commencé à
paparler de la santé, on sentait
unune exaspération par moment et
unune fermeté, je trouve que c't
llà-dessus qu'il va être jugé
fofondamentalement. Dans le
coconcret, on vient de vivre
ququelque chose de gros Québec
avavec la pandémie, je trouve qe
çaça a révélé des
dydysfonctionnements profonds ds
lele système québécois.
- - Il en a beaucoup parlé
auaujourd'hui. Ça fait plusieurs
fofois qu'il le raconte que les
gegens s'envoyaient des fax et
ququ'il n'était pas capable
d'd'avoir une vision...
- - Il en a parlé beaucoup et àn
momoment donné, il avait une
crcrédibilité.
- - Pour la santé, il a besoin
d'd'argent. Il place les pions.
IlIl a beaucoup parlé de cohésin
nanationale. Un des ingrédients
esest de dire à Ottawa d'amener
l'l'argent. On écoute.
- - C'est important aussi
quque le gouvernement fédéral
nene vienne pas se mêler de la
gegestion du réseau de la santé.
LeLe gouvernement fédéral
dodoit augmenter ses transferts
auau Québec en santé, mais il dt
papas ajouter des fonctionnaires
popour essayer de gérer
nonotre réseau de la santé.
C'C'est déjà assez complexe
cocomme ça, donc je veux être ts
clclair, Monsieur le président,
lele gouvernement du Québec
vava continuer de se battre
pour que le gouvernement fédéral
rerespecte la compétence excluse
dudu Québec en santé.
CÇa, c'est très clair.
- - Tour de table. Ce n'est pas
nonouveau, c'est très clair, mas
ilil répète des classiques, les
éléléments de base.
- - S'étaient cocasses et même n
pepeu subtils parce qu'il disai:
vovous voulez gérer mon systèmee
sasanté et vous ne payez même,
vovous payez juste 22 % du rése.
IlIl a passé ses messages. C'est
susur qu'il va continuer à
ininsister là-dessus.
- - Il se place comme étant le
chchampion de la défense des
inintérêts du Québec par rapporà
seses collègues en face.
- - Par rapport à ses collègues,
jeje dirais même au sein de la
féfédération parce qu'au bout du
cocompte, c'est souvent Québec i
sese retrouve tout seul là-dess.
CeCe n'est pas la première mena,
lala première fois que Monsieur
LeLegault lève le ton. Je ne ses
papas les s autres provinces aui
dédéterminées que lui à aller
jujusqu'au bout dans cette affae
avavec le gouvernement fédéral.
J'J'ai peur qu'encore une fois l
y y a des ententes signées entre
leles provinces et le gouvernemt
féfédéral et que Québec reste sl
avavec ses revendications.
- - Je pense que c'est un axe ts
imimportant pour François Legaut
etet c'est ce qui explique l'api
ququi lui a été reproché qu'il
avavait donné au parti
coconservateur. Ça lui permet
d'd'attaquer durement ce qui
dedevient de plus en plus son
prprincipal opposant, Gabriel
NaNadeau Dubois. dans un contexe
cacanadien, je suis un peu moins
pepessimiste que Michel. Ça
m'm'étonnerait que Québec soit
totout seul là-dedans même si
c'c'est un vrai combat à mener.
- - Je veux x vous parler avante
vovous laisser libre de Monsieur
RoRochon. On n'en avait parlé
rarapidement. Jean Rochon avec n
vivirage ambulatoire voulait que
leles gen passent moins de temps
dadans les hôpitaux, qu'il y ait
dedes soins à domicile conséque.
CeCette partie
n'n'a jamais été donné. C'est
ququand même ironique qu'il déce
auaujourd'hui et qu'on reparle s
mmêmes choses.
- - Après Monsieur Rochon, le
DoDocteur Hébert qui avait été
miministre dans le gouvernemente
PaPauline Marois disait la même
chchose. Ça a toujours été une
ququestion de sous. Quand Monsir
RoRochon s'est fait saboter sa
réréforme par son propre
gogouvernement, c'est que Monsir
BoBouchard avait décidé qu'on
atatteignait le déficit zéro et
ququ'on coupait partout. Alors a
n'n'a pas fonctionné. Il y a
ququelque chose d'un peu ironiqe
llà-dedans. Toutes les qualités
dede Monsieur Rochon sont très
réréelles. Je me souviens de lui
cocomme un homme aimable et
cocourtois, mais ce n'était pasn
bobon politicien. Il a eu des
prproblèmes comme ça dans son
prpropre gouvernement. Mais je e
sosouviens qu'à la 100 national,
soson vis-à-vis était Monsieur
PaParadis. À chaque fois, Monsir
PaParadis trouvait le cas d'un
papatient qui avait été oublié r
unune civière. Et Monsieur Rochn
ététait complètement décontenan,
nene savait plus quoi répondre.
IlIl était malheureux pour le
MoMonsieur ou la Madame, et il
sosortait perdant.
- - Ce n'était pas un batailleur
dadans l'arène politique.
- - Il était un humaniste. Souvt
àà l'Assemblée nationale, les
huhumanistes ont de la misère.
- - Et c'est lui la loi sur le
tatabac. On ne peut pas fumer
papartout.
- - Plusieurs politiciens qui ot
étété ministres de la santé et
n'n'ont pas laissé de souvenir
imimpérissable, mais Monsieur
RoRochon, on s'en souvient. C'et
unun des rares, peut-être parce
ququ'il était humain, mais il ny
enen a pas beaucoup qui ont laié
unune marque positive.
- - Surtout en santé. Laissé sa
mamarque de façon positive en
sasanté. Ça montre aussi à quel
popoint c'est difficile de faire
dede la politique. S'il avait
cocomplété son virage ambulatoi,
ilil y aurait des soins à
dodomicile, mais aussi des
seservices de première ligne. Au
dédébut du mandat, Daniel McCann
paparlait des services de premie
liligne, à quel point c'était sa
prpriorité. Presque 20 ans plus
tatard après ce grand projet, il
n'n'a jamais abouti. Ça démontre
quque chaque gouvernement a ses
obobjectifs. Son propre
gogouvernement la détournée de n
obobjectif à lui pour atteindree
dédéficit zéro. C'est ingrat
paparfois la politique.
- - Ça montre que réformer le
réréseau de la santé, c'est
exextrêmement compliqué. Et que
mmême les cerveaux qui ont étudé
sasa... si tous les éléments
n'n'arrivent pas en même temps,
c'c'est très difficile. Ensuivra
sasa. Est-ce que c'est terminé?
MeMerci beaucoup d'avoir passé
l'l'après-midi avec nous